so and the next game
the rating number is still
provisional now 23 50 they
move a bit faster so
if you win one or two games
then you are in the area where
actually only title holders come
first there is no opponent at all
which has to  call me now to
cut away that carries
los geht los geht game starts because kaká
in germany ruth johanna
stock solid david
wolf 6
I still have
n't really tackled the variant
so that 2
here somehow pretty much every
move goes for white well that with her
three would have  I then have another idea ok
makes ii 4
yes certainly very active now but
also like this he wants to hit with the queen
ok then the 3 runs that's the idea
aggressively if you don't know your way around
ok I'll take c4 and player c5
so
I actually have  in that position also
seen g5 easily but okay 7
yes also c5 he now has the 5 the
bad thing is not quite clear
to me well me  probably won't get off the train
so he jumps five it's a little
uncomfortable
then thom who can do it
one day
yes the jumper is strong
there's a threat of atom the lonely direct very
unpleasant deductions
ok jumper 26 goals the only one but
then 50 maybe
maybe that's it  still ok
ok also he is reasonable
probably good the deductions but of
course i would have i easily have the
four now maybe in the d1 springer ag 4
that will probably
win material well well ok also weakens the
pawn e5 from him something
doesn’t really look quite  sure what was
I now pulls
well okay but I can beat you free
then he would have to accept with the building
what at least
looks
ugly well
the g line can of course sometimes become
more of a problem
so
probably the weather then play with
f4 too  well
looks like a perfectly plausible
idea
and the three runners are of course still in
stock  second leg comté sixth
not nice
well maybe jumper the four
you have to be an idiot there comes at some point you
have to take the field
because the 3g 66 announced sprinkler to
take
it like that and maybe there will be an
opportunity together like 5
king heinz thumm is very active  gates
looks dangerous
I'm really
still under pressure
b 4
yes yes good already clear jumper than now
not the very safest piece
otto makes can of course only be
very weak seven times but I would like to put
something on it like e5
so f4
anyway  park it so that the clock is guarded
i should have put in b6
yes yes very unpleasant
ok maybe i can
hit better with the knight
i also have queen h4 under
certain circumstances
at that time 45 does not work there and c5 hangs
can also make active ones
maybe I can still
hit the running
yes that was clear now
first down
so that it can  n I now do
46 loses the quality how
bad it's not clear
the rest is pretty good after that
actually michael f 15
well I have to play faster
admittedly I can still
do that
yes
yes of course they are broke from now
above all I have  but I only 30
seconds
okay we just not the source okay
it's still 20 seconds
yes it's re-enactment and time unfortunately
lost what should you do
unfortunately I don't have the slightest
active possibility to
give up
race 1
very bad for the
three
well I could  Of course, simply
open here with Springer to prevent this
whole loosely the three story
I didn't really
appreciate him of course,
yes, that should probably be space,
although of course you can easily see the
quality of course,
next to Springer, the five well, difficult,
okay, not sympathetic